je tape avec la technique de l'aigle
donc c'est pas très spectaculaire avec
le bec la technique de l'aigle avec le
bec non l'aigle qui tourne audessus de
sa proie et puis qui au bout un moment
donné tombe j'ai pas appris à taper donc
mais Rael n'est pas un écrivain
excentrique on vaire comm s'il s'est
exilé au Québec il y a 6 ans c'est que
la France le considère aujourd'hui comme
le gourou d'une secte dangereuse
implanté sur le territoire français et
dans le monde
entier il était une fois un homme Claude
vorillon qui partait au travail à un
beau matin des années 70 lorsque soudain
une lumière l'a irrésistiblement attiré
vers un lieu reculé c'est comme ça que
Raël ainsi qu'il se surnommera a
rencontré pour la première fois les
extraterrestres à partir de là on aurait
pu imaginer un nouveau scénario pour les
envahisseurs ou X Files et sourire en
frémissant devant les nouvelles
aventures du David Vincent français sauf
que raë a fondé une secte qui a
proliféré dans le monde entier depuis 30
ans et qu'il est aujourd'hui au sommet
d'une organisation extrêmement puissante
accusé de pédophilie et de dée
financière aux frontières du raë
reportage de Cyril Devau Éric de
l'agneau c'est ça c'est la réplique
exacte de de l'engin dans lequel je suis
monté le 13 décembre 73 dans le puis de
la sola près de CL monontferrand ce
jour-là ce fut sa première rencontre
jeallais à mon bureau il était environ
9h du matin et quelque chose m'a
guidé j'ai pas arrêté ma voiture et j'ai
continué j'étais guidé
il a fallu que j'aille dans un dans le
le parc des volcans d'auver et dans le
pu de la sola j'ai continu à pied
jusqu'au centre du
cratère et là j'ai vu une lumière
blanche clignotante dans le ciel très
violente un engin est apparu en forme
d'une cloche aptie fait d'un métal
argenté très
brillant un descendu par l'escalier
qu'on voit là qui est sous
j'ai vu deux genses puis le corps entier
d'un être très petit il s'est avancé
vers moi avec beaucoup d'amour
d'harmonie un regard extraordinaires des
yeux très en amande comme certains
japonais ensuite il m'a demandé de le
suivre dans l'engin ce que j'ai fait et
ça c'est le début de l'histoire Claude
vorillon aurait été investi d'une
mission à cet instant révéler aux
humains que la vie sur Terre a été créée
il y a 25000 ans seulement par des
extraterrestres et que ces derniers
s'apprêtent à revenir avant 2035
[Musique]
Claude vorillon et leur prophète mais
les extraterrestres n'ont pas aimé son
nom ils l'ont rebaptisé
[Musique]
Raël ces êtres sont venus sur Terre il y
a très très longtemps ils sont ils
vivent sur une autre planète ils
s'appellent les Elohim e l o h M
pourquoi ils sont venus sur Terre parce
qu'ils avaient avait atteint la même
même niveau technologie qu'on connaît
actuellement sur Terre à savoir création
de la vie en laboratoire clonage et
voyage dans
l'espace ils ont choisi une planète dans
l'univers avec des conditions
climatiques qui leur semblaient
positives c'était la terre il y avait
pas de vie à cette époque là sur terre
il y avait rien ils sont arrivés ils ont
fabriqué d'immenses laboratoires et dans
ces laboratoires grâce à l'ingénierie
génétique la maîtrise du clonage de
l'ADN et de toutes ces choses-là ils ont
fabriqué tout vie sur la
[Musique]
terre il y a dans la Bible hébraïque qui
est la plus ancienne le mot Elohim qui
veut dire en hébreu non pas Dieu mais
ceux qui sont venus du ciel et qui est
au pluriel c'est très important donc la
Bible raconte ce qu'ils ont fait mais vu
par des primitifs pour qui tout ce qui
venait du ciel ne pouvait être que
surnaturel ou divin les gens évolués
doivent donc lire la Bible de cette
façon l'arche de Noé n'était en fait qu'
un vaisseau spatial affraité par les
Élohims les anges n'étaient que des
extraterrestres en visite sur terre nos
ancêtres auraient confondu leur fusée à
réacteur avec des ailes et leur casque
de cosmonaut avec la sainte auréole
Jésus serait le fruit d'une terrienne et
d'un
extraterrestre ce sont tout à la fois la
Bible et les évangiles réécrits version
XF il suffirait de remplacer le mot Dieu
par extraterrestre et tout deviendrait
lumineux notre nouveau prophète écrit
donc un livre modestement intitulé Le
livre qui dit la vérité ce recueil des
messages donnés par les extraterrestres
paraît en
1973 j'ai lu ces messages je les ai
relus et relu j'ai dis mais c'est c'est
tellement intelligent c'est tellement
plus intelligent que toutes les
explications qu'on m'a donné jusque- là
et je pense j'aiété le premier aélien
l'ennui c'est que les révélations de
Claude vorillon sont déjà le fond de
commerce de beaucoup de romans de
science-fiction des années 60 donc bien
antérieur un exemple le peuple du ciel
écrit par brinley le port trench en 1970
soit 3 ans avant le livre de Claude
vorillon il imaginait déjà une création
de la vie sur Terre par des
extraterrestres qui s'appelaient
[Musique]
Elohim Claude vourillon a beaucoup de
chance il dit avoir fait une deuxième
rencontre avec les extraterrestres un
cas très rare dans les anales chez tous
ceux qui ont croisé les soucoupes
volantes et là il a droit au grand jeu
les extraterrestres l'emmènent sur leur
planète il n'y a pas de
témoins on est parti sur dans un relais
spatial qui est un petit peu comme le
relais spatial que les hommes sont en
train de construire maintenant on a
changé de vaisseau et là on est arrivé
sur la planète où il vient et où j'ai pu
voir une civilisation extraordinaire qui
est notre futur en fait c'est quoi
exactement ben c'est une civilisation
qui a 25000 ans d'avance sur nous
donc les plus avancés de nos
scientifiques ne peuvent même pas
imaginer ce que c'est il y a pas de
pollution il y a pas d'argent il y a pas
de travail mais ça arrive très vite on
va connaître ça très vite mais c'est
c'est c'est un monde merveilleux c'est
ce que les les les primitifs appelai le
paradis les extraterrestres ont posé une
condition pour apporter leur paradis sur
terre en 2035 Claude vorillon doit leur
construire une ambassade ils en auraient
eux-mêmes dessiné la maquette la voici
une piste d'atterrissage pour souscoupe
volante une grande villa et une
piscine coût du projet million de francs
pour trouver cet argent Claude Villon
décide en
1976 de fonder son église et de recruter
des
fidèle 24 ans ont passé l'ambassade
n'est toujours pas construite seul
projet immobilier à être sorti de terre
ufoland au Québec un parc d'attraction
ouvert au public enté 10 dollars RA nous
a interdit d'en filmer l'intérieur comme
il voulait nous interdire de filmer ceci
l'arrière du bâtiment et son immense
façade c'est ici que réside le Prophète
au milieu d'un domaine privé de 150
hectares il y rédige actuellement son 6e
livre en tenue de cosmonaut avec une
technique de frappe très
personnelle je tape avec la technique de
l'aigle donc c'est pas très
spectaculaire avec le bec la technique
de l'aigle avec le bec non l'aigle qui
tourne audessus de sa proie et puis qui
au boutun moment donné tombe j'ai pas
appris à taper donc mais Rael n'est pas
un écrivain
excentrique s'il s'est exilé au Québec
il y a 6 ans c'est que la France le
considère aujourd'hui comme le gourou
d'une secte dangereuse implanté sur le
territoire français et dans le monde
entier la première bombe atomique
Hiroshima
1945 quelques mois plus tard Claude
vorillon nî en France de père inconnu ce
père inconnu selon lui c'était un
extraterrestre et le petit Claude a été
conçu pour sauver la planète du feu
nucléaire
j'ai été fait pour ça mon père est l'un
des leurs ils ont choisi ma mère et moi
à mon insu j'ai été élevé sans savoir ce
qui se
prépara et en attendant l'Annonciation
il tente de devenir le clone de jacqu
Brell sous le nom de Claude
s
[Musique]
je 20
ANSR
[Musique]
va
Pr
sa carrière se résume à ce petit moment
de gloire sur un plateau de l'ORTF en
mai 1966 et à quelques disques échec
dans la chanson il se découvre alors une
nouvelle
[Musique]
passion Claude vorillon devient pilote
automobile et journaliste sportif il
fonde sa maison d'édition et sa propre
revue autopp jusqu'en
1973 c'est à cette date que les
extraterrestres lui demande de tout
abandonner pour devenir leur
prophète des centaines de personnes le
prennent alors pour un vrai
Messi il adopte un look de prophète
organise des pèlerinages sur les lieux
de ses soi-disants rencontres avec les
[Musique]
extraterrestres il prêche la paix les ex
terrestre et la liberté
sexuelle son discours ressemble à celui
de l'époque remise en cause de la
famille de l'autorité et de la religion
[Musique]
entouré de fidèles Claude vorillon
commence à se prendre pour raë il crée
officiellement son organisation
religieuse le mouvement raélien une
association loi 1901 qui a pour but
concret de construire une ambassade aux
[Musique]
extraterrestres il forme ses premiers
disciples les
guides à l'époque en France des
mouvements comme celui-ci ne sont pas
étiquetés secte et ne sont pas qualifiés
d'organisation
dangereuse ils amusent plutôt on pari
sur leur aspect
[Musique]
éphémère 27 ans plus tard dans un jardin
public de
Genève RAM Amira RA alias claud Villon a
le cheveux plus rar la barbe mieux
taillé mais le rituel reste le
[Musique]
même ce jourl 21 candidats venus du
monde entier défile devant lui pour être
baptisé 4 jours par an à 15h précise le
Prophète prétend entrer en contact
télépathique avec les extraterrestres
par ce simple geste il leur
transmettrait le code génétique du
baptisé ainsi le baptisé pourra être
recréé après sa mort dans le Paradis
extraterrestre c'est le premier pas vers
la vie éternelle selon la doctrine du
mouvement
[Applaudissements]
raélien complètement envoûé à l'issue de
la cérémonie les baptisés nous parlent
de nouveau départ dans la vie de
renaissance c'était fantastique
le plus beau jour de ma vie de toute ma
vie et qu'avez-vous
ressenti un grand sentiment de liberté
oui de liberté j'ai eu l'impression
d'exprimer qui je suis
vraiment de l'amour ce n rien d'autre
que
cela
c'était vraiment palpitant je dois dire
que c'était très beau j'éta très très
aimé ça n'a pas été très facile pour moi
car j'étais très attaché à la religion
catholique donc ça a été un choix
difficile très
difficile et comment vous vous sentez
maintenant
pour entrer dans cette église les
nouveaux adeptes renoncent à leur
ancienne religion les catholiques par
exemple font acte d'apostasie ils
doivent écrire à leur évêque pour
demander d'être radiés des listes du
baptême les nouveaux baptisés renoncent
aussi à certains codes de la société ils
ne doivent plus voter et doivent adopter
le calendrier raéien qui débute avec
l'explosion d'Hiroshima en
45 super bonne journée ils ne doivent
plus consommer d'alcool de cigarettes et
de drogue ils s'engagent enfin à de
nouveaux
adeptes et puis il y a la gestuelle les
étreintes elles sont partout présentes
on va le voir elles ont une importance
toute particulière dans ce
mouvement sans baptême une fois qu'on a
pris connaissance des messages pas de
vie éternelle chez leslè car en plus de
l'éternité raë propose à ses adeptes des
plaisirs bien plus terrestres c'est ce
que nous allons découvrir lors d'un
rassemblement du mouvement dans un hôtel
à
Genève
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car les baptêmes sont toujours précédés
de rit qui paraissent moins
[Applaudissements]
sacrés au cours de son voyage sur la
planète des ellohims Rael aurait
découvert le
paradis selon son récit des femmes
robots soumises à tous ses désirs lui
ont offert une danse envoûtante et
voluptueuse avant de lui faire passer la
plus folle nuit de son
existence c'est ce qu'il enseigne à ses
adeptes au cours de réunions comme
celle-ci des enfants y assistent comme
cette toute jeune
[Musique]
fille la convention raélienne ressemble
par moment à une boîte de nuit
érotique les gens y applaudissent comme
dans un club de stripteas sauf qu'il n'y
a pas d'enfant dans les clubs de
stripteas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
auparavant les fidèles ont eu droit à un
discours du prophète de
2h30 vous êtes amoureux des messages oui
es amoureux de Raël et tu messager oui
mais avant tout vous êtes amoureux de
votre liberté liberté amour de mots que
nous avons entendu plus de 1000 fois en
3 jours pourtant dans la salle des
hommes et des femmes équipés de tokiwi
et d'orette scrutent en permanence les
réactions des auditeurs notre équipe a
été étroitement surveillée et
constamment filmée par le service
d'ordre raélien toutêtre a le droit de
penser ce qu'il veut des droits de
l'homme qui existe il est interdit au
raen d' le prophète ou de lui poser une
question en revanche il est vivement
conseillé de prendre des notes d'écouter
attentivement et d'applaudir parfois
plus de 10
minutes et puis l'ancien chanteur prend
sa guitare il a enfin trouvé son
[Musique]
public pas beaucoup de s sur la guitare
en moi je m'entends pas en tout
[Musique]
cas c'est formidable comm les
regardez bien les choristes il les
appelle ses
anges leur signe distinctif une plume
qu'elle porte autour du
[Musique]
coup t ensem la plume blanche désigne
des jeunes filles qui ont accepté de se
soumettre au désir du prophète mais
conserve le droit de côtoyer d'autres
partenaires je dirit même même qu'ils
sont l'amour de notre vie
plume rose ce sont les élus des
extraterrestres pendant une durée
indéterminée qui peut aller d'un jour à
l'éternité elles s'engagent à réserver
leur sexualité aux
extraterrestres et au
[Musique]
prophètes qu' sont l'amour de notre
vie toutes ces jeunes fille auraient
choisi librement nous disent les raliens
de respecter le code de conduite des
anges de Raël dévoilé sur Internet par
un ancien
adepte on y découvre que les
extraterrestres et leur prophète Raël
exigent la soumission totale des
anges ce sont des individus qui sont
prêts à tout sacrifier pour eux tant
leur vie professionnelle que sentimental
et même leur vie tout court ils seraient
prêt à donner leur vie pour protéger
leurs créateurs et leurs
prophètes quand une personne est prête à
tout sacrifier pour un autre individu et
ça tout même dans le TEX s dit prête à
sacrifier sa vie même donc quand un
individu est rendu à se soumettre à un
autre à ce point-là vous prête à faire
n'importe quoi Éric Lamarche a rendu
public ce code de conduite des anges de
Raël nous l'avons retrouvé dans un
quartier populaire de Montréal ce
passionné d'extraterrestre a été membre
du mouvement raéien canadien plusieurs
années avant d'ouvrir les yeux
aujourd'hui Éric Lamarche a décidé de
révéler le visage caché du mouvement
raéen
moi je suis convaincu quand j'ai rentré
dans le mouvement en 1989 si j'aurais
été aussi belle fille que je suis beau
bonhomme une belle petite blonde aux
yeux bleus avec une stature bien min je
suis convaincu que j'aurais passer des
moments intimes
avec selon Éric Lamarche pour gravir les
échelons de la hiérarchie raélienne il
serait déconseillé de dire non au
Prophète que moi j'ai j'ai déjà jasé
avec une Ren qui l' encore puis elle a
eu des invitation de RAL puis elle a
refusé puis d'autres aen lui ont dit
mais qu'est-ce que tu fais là vas-y sa
tuas la chance de passer un moment avec
le dernier des prophètes voyons tout le
monde sauterait sur cette occasion dans
le code des anges on trouve aussi des
consignes sur le profil des gens à
recruter pour le mouvement de nombreuses
jeunes femmes désespéré par le manque de
spiritualité et la superficialité de la
société cherchant à oublier leur
désarroi dans la drogue l'alcool ou le
suicide à ces personnes fragiles Rael
prône la méditation
sensuelle grâce au stage de méditation
sensuel RA pré chaque année un
enseignement de la plus haute importance
sur cette vidéo interne présenté à tous
ceux que le mouvement veut recrutter il
est officiellement question de
sensualité et non de
sexualité Quim àme la méditation
sensuelle c'est une méditation classique
agrémentée d'une technique de massage
sur toutes les parties du corps qu'
n'est pas interdit de pratiquer
entièrement
dénudé mais cela la vidéo ne le montre
pas pour le découvrir les nouveaux
arrivants doivent suivre des stages
d'éveil et de méditation
sensuelle après le sexe et le pouvoir
troisième pilier fondamental de la secte
l'argent pour comprendre comment il
entre dans les caisses nous avons suivi
des adeptes au cours d'une parade
bonjour pas de
réaction ce jour-là dans les rues de
Genève ils appellent à une conférence
sur les
extraterrestrre il revendiqu simplement
nous disent-il le droit au
prosélitisme et nous allons aujourd'hui
faire de la publicité pour faire
connaître ça au public afin que les gens
sachent ce qui se passe sur notre
planète et que les pouvoirs obscurs en
place qui veulent cacher ça au public et
bien nous nous allons le dé all cet
après-midi au public de
Genève comme toujours le défilé est
encadré par des membres du service
d'ordre relié par oreillett en général
l'accueil des passants est assez
indifférent mais parfois l'un d'entre
eux intervient pour moi ce qui est
dangereux c'est pas la joie de ces
hommes parce que s'ils sont joyeux
eux-mêmes c'est bien pour moi ce qui est
dangereux c'est l'embrigadement
embrigader des gens qui sont dans la
souffrance qui sont des drogués qui sont
et dès qu'ils sont mal et qu'il faut se
rattacher à quelque chose ce genre de
vous l'avez vérifié non laiss
laisse-mo devant la
camé
je moi ma voix je pas fait dans
les j'ai pas dit que vous étiez des
drogués j'ai pas dit que vous étiez des
drogués j'ai dit que vous êtes heureux
tant mieux pour
vous j'ai dit que ce qui est
malhonnête malhonnte c'est d'embrigadier
des gens qui sont dans la misère je
crois que 80% des gens qui regard ça se
rendrontte
c'est mais si quelqu'un prête une
oreille attentive on lui propose
quelques
achats un membre de notre équipe muni
d'une caméra cachée s'approche de la
parade dès son arrivée une jeune
rélienne lui tente un
tract il joue l'intéressé elle lui
propose aussitôt le livre de
raë coû combien ça
29 20 fr 29 29 fr Suiss ou il refuse
quelques minutes plus tard un autre
raélien revient à la charge il cherche à
le convaincre de l'existence des
extraterrestres confidentiel a été remis
au Président République française au
Premier ministre monsieur Chirac à quoi
doit-on se préparer dans ce dossier il
disent un contact il lui propose aussi
le livre de
Raël
ça ou alors en friss 2 fr vous pouvez
faire un ch si vous voulez aussi he
monsieur si vous êtes il refuse encore
mais comme il semble intéressé on
l'invite au rassemblement raellien dans
l'hôtel de
Genève pour assister au discours de Raël
il doit passer à la caisse prix de
l'entrée 200 francs français on lui
remet ce badge daté de l'an 55 après
Hiroshima et ce bulletin d'adhésion au
mouvement s'il veut devenir membre il
est invité à verser 3 % de ses revenus à
l'antenne nationale plus 7 % à l'antenne
internationale du mouvement soit au
total 10 % de ses revenus nets après
impôt selon nos informations tout cet
argent alimente plusieurs comptes
numérotés dans des banques de Genève en
Suisse un paradis
fiscal mais tout cet argent raë dit ne
pas en percevoir le moindre centime pour
être très clair je ne reçois
contrairement au pape et aux év
catholique aucun salaire de du mouvement
Ren aucun salaire pas un centime
mouvement rélien reçoit des cotisations
pour la poursuite de ses buts à côté de
ça il existe la fondation rélienne et là
cet argent c'est pour mon bien-être
personnel la Fondation c'est donc
l'argent de poche chaque raéien doit y
verser 1 % de ses revenus en plus des 10
% pour le mouvement la Fondation est
également alimentée par les droits
d'auteur de
Ra ces livres sont édités par sa propre
maison d'édition installée à vadus au
Luxembourg un autre paradis fiscal tous
les raéliens sont obligés de les acheter
comme ils doivent acheter la médaille
officielle du mouvement ici c'est marqué
que à tous les r de la planète à partir
de maintenant seul les médailles
officielles produit par la Fondation
raen ont le droit d'être vendu dans les
différents pays et C et ell seul sont
magnétisé par elle qui refusera
désormais de magnétiser tout autre
médaille médaille badge autocollant
livre sont commercialisés par une
association la dira officiellement cette
association est à but non
lucratif pourtant en
1996 l'antenne française de la dira a
fait l'objet d'un redressement fiscal
d'environ 1300000 francs pour profit
dissimulé ajouté à un autre contentieux
de 503000 francs pour versement de
salaire dissimulés par l'antenne
française du mouvement la facture
s'élève à près de 1900000 francs selon
nos informations le fisque Français n'a
toujours pas récupéré son
argent il y a toujours de l'argent
il n plus et cet argent il sert à quoi
alors il peut avoir de usages enrichir
le gourou à financer son train de vie il
peut avoir aussi un autre usage qui
n'est pas contradictoire c'est
développer l'implantation de la secte
profit du Gour au profit du gourou et de
ces fantasmes dominateurs pour certaines
sectes sur la planète tout
entière poursuivi par l'État
français'est installé au Québec
etentobir
oui Québec je suis québécois maintenant
je suis plus français et je me sens
québécois et j'aime le Québec pas pour
le paysage pas pour le climat évidment
pour les
gens car les Québécois ne considèrent
pas le mouvement ralien comme une secte
mais comme une congrégation
religieuse à ce titre Ra et les sont
exonérés d'impôt ce qui leur avait
toujours été refusé par la
France RA aurait déjà recruté près de
5000 adeptes au Québec à chaque fois
qu'il rentre de voyage les anges du
Canada l'attendent à
l'aéroport au cours de notre enquête
nous découvrons alors un projet bien
plus effrayant raë s'apprête à franchir
une nouvelle frontière dans la
manipulation des hommes grâce à la
manipulation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
génétique
nous sommes chez Stéphane 31 ans et
Marina 22 ans un couple
raélien il est informaticien elle est
étudiante au
beauard toutes mes aves ont toujours une
application philosophique qui est lié à
quelque chose qui qui est dans
l'enseignement
de Marina a été choisi par RA pour être
la mère porteuse du premier clone humain
il s'agit d'un jeune garçon mort en
basage raë a convaincu ses parents qu'il
pourrait le ressusciter par clonage
moyen an 16 millions de
francs j'ai toujours voulu porter un
enfant fait que déjà et puis ma vie vous
avez dû le remarquer est trop speedé
pour que je puisse en
garder que je pourrais pas tout de suite
en tout cas avoir d'enfant donc ça me
permet d'avoir un enfant sans avoir à le
garder en même temps j'ai rencontré les
parents de l'enfant et il le désire
tellement cet enfant là c'est tellement
un beau geste d'amour que moi j'ai envie
de leur faire ce cadeaul et de leur
permettre de retrouver leur enfant raell
veut clonner l'enfant mort comme on a
cloné la brobie d'Olly il y a quelques
années des cellules de l'enfant auraient
été conservver dans un laboratoire selon
les riens il s'agirait tout simplement
de prélever l'ADN c'est-à-dire le code
génétique d'une de ses cellules et de
l'implanter dans un noveocite de Marina
grâce à un choc
électrique le nouvel embryon serait
ensuite réimplanté dans l'utérus de
Marina
elle accoucherait alors selon les réiens
d'une réplique exacte de l'enfant mort
quelques mois plus
tôt lorsqu'on demande aux adeptes
raéliens s'ils ne doutent pas de temps
en temps des visions de leur prophète
voici ce qu'il
répondent admettons qu'on me prouve un
jour que c'est pas vrai que que ça a
jamais existé j'aurais jamais un seul
regret du choix que j'aurais fait et de
la vie que j'aurais mené parce que
j'aurais jamais pu avoir une vie plus
belle que celle que j'ai aujourd'hui
mainant que les OLE m'arrivent pas là on
nous dit écoutez là votre truc là
c'était de la TH c'était de la foutinse
puis j'aurais été heureux tout ce temps
là puis encore j'y crois pas là pour moi
c'est je suis convaincu que ça va
arriver et c'est pour ça que je
participe avec tant de passion et mais
sinon fantastique je vais aller
remercier à elle je vais lui dire à elle
je comprends pas comment tu as fait pour
inventer tout ça là mais tu m'a rendu
heureux merci le
bonheur
dans bonhe
on ne possède aucune précision sur la
fortune personnelle de Claude vorillon
alias
RA il aura 90 ans en 2035 et si les
extraterrestres n'arrivent pas cette
annéel il aura tout de même vécu
confortablement grâce à ceux qui croient
en
lui son mouvement revendique aujourd'hui
50000 adeptes dans 84 pays sur les 5
continents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]